this video is brought to you by people
just like you people who watch and enjoy
the videos we put out every single week
but the specific people who have made
this video possible are our supporters
on patreon they signed up to give us a
monthly contribution that goes directly
to the production of these episodes
so we'd like to start off today by
saying thank you to them and if you'd
like to join them you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro and sign up
today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
scum is kind of a rude name isn't it I
mean sure it feels kind of appropriate
when you're wading through murky Waters
and you feel that disconcerting
combination of fuzzy and Slick textures
sliding against the bottom of your feet
you might not be able to see it but you
can sure feel it whether or not you want
to and it feels like anything could be
there anything at all but even still
scum that seems a little judgmental
technically the word scum was originally
used in The 14th Century to describe the
frothy layers on top of liquids it
wasn't until the 16th century that it
began to be used more as an insult
against people so sure scum was probably
meant more to describe the way Pond scum
obscures our water then is a moral
criticism of those green mats but there
is actually something kind of scummy
about Pond scum
it's not something they necessarily
intend to be in fact it's a
contradiction of sorts a process that
takes them from an organism that
provides oxygen to its fellow Pond
neighbors to an organism that suffocates
them
there are different types of green that
accumulate in our ponds including clouds
of cyanobacteria that disperse when you
wave a stick through them but Pond scum
is different if you drag a stick through
Pond scum it'll come out of the water
looking like a wet mat woven together
with green threads
it looks like that because that is what
pond scum is those mats are made out of
filamentous algae a range of species who
bring a mixture of greens and yellows
and Browns to their joint Endeavor up
close with a microscope you can see the
individual characteristics that make up
those algae almost as if you're
examining the silk threads that have
been stitched together to form a
glorious tapestry and by glorious
tapestry we of course mean Pond scum
and yes that feels like a contradiction
but look at these Spyro Gyra and their
distinct spiral shapes that their
chloroplasts wind through them they're
like a spectacular off-color candy cane
when you feel Pond scum on you this is
what you're feeling beautiful
microscopic strands built from chains of
cells that divide and defied to elongate
the thread binding their lives together
filamentous algae usually begin growing
at the bottom of ponds in Shallow areas
where there is plenty of light to drive
their photosynthesis as the algae
divides and extends its chains the
filaments begin to tangle and weave
together forming a dense mat because the
algae are photosynthesizing they are
also releasing oxygen into the water
oxygen that gets trapped is Bubbles
within the growing mat those bubbles
lift the mat of filamentous algae up so
that it's no longer trapped at the
bottom of the pond and that creates a
sort of floating city with threads of
algae that house many residents of the
microcosmos
in the background here you can see the
blurry form of rotifers snapping up any
snack that passes close enough for it to
grasp and here we can see a strange hypo
trick popping out from underneath the
filament as it feeds maybe using the
algae like a log to hide under before it
ambushes its unsuspecting prey and if
you look hard enough you might find an
aliasoma our favorite polka dotted worm
sandwiched between strands of algae
maybe casually wiggling around on its
way to a cannibalistic Gathering yes
that's a thing we have a whole episode
about it if you want to know more
all in all it turns out that pond scum
is both made of beautiful algae threads
and houses all sorts of fascinating
creatures you might be tempted to call
it a little microbial Utopia but James
our master of microscopes often gets
emails from people who want to know how
to get rid of the scum growing in their
artificial ponds but they're so
wonderful you might say now that you
know that underlying all that muck is a
wondrous world of worms and rotifers and
mysterious creatures housed in a living
home that sustains them and yet every
year ponds around the world become the
site of a battle between the filamentous
algae that come to dominate them and
well pretty much everything else in the
pond
this is a different situation from say
the cyanobacteria we mentioned earlier
or certain algal blooms that can kill
their fellow Pond residents by producing
toxins filamentous algae wouldn't do
something nefarious like poison their
neighbors they just suffocate them
instead
the organisms living inside ponds rely
on oxygen that gets dissolved in the
water some of that oxygen comes from
outside the pond diffusing and
circulating into the water but of course
filamentous algae and their fellow
photosynthetic Pond residents contribute
to the oxygen content as well which is
quite kind the filamentous algae the
problem is that they don't just make
oxygen they also consume it and if the
weather conditions aren't quite right
the algae will consume more oxygen than
they make
this depletion can be exacerbated by
nutrients like phosphorus and nitrogen
which might enter the pond from
fertilizer or runoff from around the
pond these nutrients cause the algae to
grow and grow and grow until their
numbers skew the oxygen balance in their
favor and against everyone else's
and even if the algae all die off at
once like through the use of a chemical
algaecide that doesn't solve the oxygen
problem you've now provided the bacteria
in the pond plenty of dead algae to
decompose which means they consume a lot
of oxygen instead
that doesn't mean that you can't use
chemicals to kill algae however it
requires careful consideration of the
pond conditions and the algae involved
to make sure that it makes sense to turn
to those algaecides there are other
methods for short-term control of these
algae populations like physically
removing them with a rake or using
water-soluble dyes that limit sunshine
to the algae when they're still at the
bottom of the pons
but these are short-term Solutions the
fact is that long-term approaches mean
preventing excess nutrients from
entering the ponds in the first place
whether by thinking through our
fertilizer choices or adding buffers to
our ponds to prevent runoff from
entering or any number of other
approaches that help maintain a healthy
pond
because maybe in the long term dealing
with filamentous algae is rooted in
acknowledging the way that they suit the
word scum in all senses of the word they
are grimy and gross but also something
that is simply a part of the water and
in between the negative connotations of
the word and its more neutral Origins is
something wondrous that requires balance
on our end to maintain
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us those names you're
seeing on the screen right now are some
of our patreon patrons and they are the
reason that this show can exist if you'd
like to join them in supporting Journey
to the microcosmos you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro to get
weekly wallpapers and monthly uncut
videos if you'd like to see more from
our master of microscopes James Weiss
you can check out jam and germs on
Instagram and if you'd like to see more
from us there's probably a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Music]
foreign